this week we're talking about better
business analytics data warehousing and
translation AI welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news Google and looker are
joining forces to push cloud-based
business analytics even further this
means the addition of several new
features to Google cloud platform
including the power to define metrics
once and then apply them across datasets
built in applications for industry
specific use cases and data
visualization tools read more about what
the acquisition of liquor means for GCP
customers on the cloud blog then try it
out but our roster doesn't end there
we're also bringing snowflake a leading
cloud-based data warehouse provider into
the fold in this case through a
partnership customers who already use
snowflake for powerful data insights can
now get seamless access to GCPs AI tools
and of course our newly reinforced data
analytics capabilities see what a
partner first strategy looks like in
practice on tcp we at Google have been
dealing with translation for a while so
we're excited to announce v3 of our
translation API listening to our
customers we added new features like
choosing between pre-trained and custom
models batch translations and more
granular control over specific words and
phrases enjoy a smarter version of the
same powerful translation API without
upgrading anything archery knowing how
to secure your kubernetes environment is
pretty important the good news it's
never been easier to learn how thanks to
our self-paced lesson series on quick
labs whether you're running kubernetes
yourself using our google kubernetes
engine managed service or using anthos
complete this quest to learn the ins and
outs of migration monitoring and
security get started if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you